buonasera
di cosa parliamo stasera la scienza è
una storia bellissima che merita di
essere raccontata e merita di essere
scritta e questo è lo scopo della mia
generazione come di quelle che mi hanno
preceduto
ora in ambito scientifico quando te la
barona teoria passi tramite tre fasi in
continuazione la proponi è la prima cosa
che ti diranno no questo è pazzo
questa cosa non è possibile non è
neanche plausibile e il vaneggiamento di
un folle poi mano a mano che accumuli e
accumuli prove perché la scienza va
avanti tramite prove dicono ma forse
forse potrebbe avere ragione sai forse
forse va bene forse è possibile
arrivato alla fine quando ormai è
chiaramente concreta ma da tutti diranno
sì ma era ovvio cioè l'ha detto lui ma
lo sapevamo tutti già da prima
ecco un paio di esempi storici per
motivarci a non mollare
allora evoluzione
una delle teorie più famose del mondo
prima di darwin c'era la maschera prima
della marca e nulla veniva proposta
propugnata la teoria secondo la quale
gli animali erano quelli sempre stati
quelli intoccabili mai toccati e se
provate ad azzardare parola attenzione
perché una cella il clero ce l'aveva
oppure perché senza problemi arrivano
anche e giustamente nota con gli
esperimenti sulle giostre di ho
impressione che la giraffa col tempo
abbia allungato il collo per necessità
di prendere gli alberi più alti perché
gli alberi più bassi stavano finendo per
il contrasto con altri predatori
guardano a questa teoria è plausibile
però non lo so fa un po strano e come
vaccinate che io andando in palestra poi
riesca ad avere un figlio che nasce un
palestrato
non sono un po un po strano però è stata
la dell'establishment per più di 50 anni
nella marxismo darwin rivoluziona questa
cosa dicendo a capire che le variazioni
sono casuali e poi la selezione non
sceglie il più forte
sceglie il più adatto all'ambiente ma
non dobbiamo pensare che la marca sia
stato completamente buttato anzi
epigenetica che cos'è levi genetica e
l'idea che la tua vita del tuo stile di
vita di vivere notifichi l'espressione
la tua espressione genetica questa
immagine del time molto bella dice
perché il tuo dna non è il suo destino
non necessariamente tutto quello che c'è
nel tuo consiglio genetico sarà quello
che ti rappresenterà che
rappresenteranno i due figli e allo
stesso modo non tutto è possibile capire
solo soltanto dal codice genetico alti
esempi sammer wise proprio per sperare
sembra quasi un medico lavora in
ospedale e come tutti i medici in quanto
proprio si annoia tanto tanto tanto
tanto tanto inizia a leggere statistiche
statistica del suo ospedale e cosa vede
che sto ospedale c a due piani al piano
di sopra
nascono bambini ostetriche al piano di
sotto le partorienti vengono fatte
partorire da medici è uno potrebbe
pensare bene medico più qualificato che
brava farla partorire meglio e cosa no
da sempre vuole essere quello che vedete
in questa curva in rosa e il piano per
quello che sembra questo mentre quella
che vedete più scuro era quella del
secondo piano che paragonabile a quello
di un altro ospedale
i casi di morte erano aumentati di
tantissimo se no questo non riesce a
darsi una spiegazione di questa cosa
prende in esame tutte le possibili
ipotesi forse perché al piano terra
passa il prete per dare le benedizioni
sempre wired.it altre di entrare non ti
avvicinare alle partorienti non si sa
mai
non va bene se no veste prende in
considerazione altre cose forse perché
sono più esposte alla luce chiude tutto
il primo piano non funziona bene vado a
questo punto per esclusione
togliendo tutto deve restare l'ipotesi
che la più senza che però il nome aveva
preso in considerazione l'idea che al
piano terra avesse aperto il
dipartimento di anatomia patologica e
medici avevano
la brutta abitudine in quegli anni
facevano le autopsie si lavano le mani
con acqua e sapone e davano a far
partorire come se nulla fosse
ebbe per parare morte batteri ovunque se
ne volesse intelligentemente 19 lavoro
fate una cosa non vi lavate le mani solo
con l'acqua e sapone e la seconda linea
grigia verticale che vede tema iniziate
a lavarle anche con quello che sarebbe
diventata poi la clorexidina quindi
inizia a fare disinfezione prima del
parto e livelli di mortalità cadono di
nuovo a terra
ora una cosa del genere se questo
dovrebbe essere un salvatore che
dovrebbero dedicare le statue nelle
città
e invece se mi vuoi essere a 60
linguistico di cene mentale picchiato
dalle guardie perché viene considerato
un pazzo un pazzo completo
l'establishment medico lo caccia dicendo
tu hai fatto una cosa per cui non eri
demandato non decidi tu quali sono le
procedure dell'ospedale come ti sei
permesso di dire gli altri medici cosa
dovevano fare gli altri ospedali non lo
vogliono perché meglio e una patata
bollente
nessuno lo vuole sempre volesse finisce
malissimo peccato peccato che finisca
malissimo quando si stava fermando la
teoria nigro biotico master pastore ci
arriverà per tutte altre vie
lo dimostrerà persone avrà la fortuna di
vivere un ambiente molto più aperto dove
la sua teoria sarà accettata è infatti
l'immagine che vedete qua si chiama
stretto invece si scaglia è una cosa
molto carina dipartimento di
microbiologia sparsi per le varie
università ogni anno fanno questa specie
di concorso d'arte proviamo a dipingere
con i microbatteri bene questo qua e se
dicesse sky ha fatto uno stretto
vincesse molto carino questa una casa di
vetro
ora queste sono degli esempi che devono
spingerci a fare due cose 1 hanno
mollato perché se non lotti per le tue
idee o tu non vali niente o le tue idee
non valgono niente
quindi se sei convinto di quello che
dice se sei convinto di quello che spara
in porta avanti fino al fuoco e due
devono spronarci a ricordare che a volte
l'esito non è necessariamente quello che
è stato il viaggio la mia generazione
la legge nell'azione si trova in un
ambiente medico dove hai
8.000 miliardi di articoli
sull'argomento un fantastico perfetto
qualcuno di questo articolo dice la
stessa cosa dell'articolo precedente
follia agli articoli che si
contraddicono sulle cose più basilari di
questo mondo quello che tu vorresti fare
e come avete visto in questo breve
stacco di nanni moretti ad aprile
nascondersi tutto questo articolo e di
rotta io non c'entro niente non lo dico
io o diva loro perdita con loro la colpa
non è mia ma non puoi fare questo medico
non può fare questo è una persona di
scienza non può fare questo che dobbiamo
ragionare dobbiamo essere critici che ha
lanciato l'allarme sulle pubblicazioni e
li ringrazio famedi semplice attenzione
c'è una frode nell'episodio è diventato
troppo facile pubblicare non ci sono
controlli non ci sono supervisioni è
diventato pericoloso riuscire a
estrapolare un concetto da una revisione
bene la nostra generazione come si deve
porre sotto questo punto di vista e
maniera molto semplice pensare ma nella
critica che è la cosa più banale e
contemporaneamente più difficile da fare
a questo mondo perché pensa alla materia
critica implica uno sforzo notevole
anche sulle cose di base però è l'unico
modo per poter trarre conclusioni
l'articolo già esistente quindi prendi
tutti gli articoli sull'argomento scarta
quelli che sono chiaramente farsi
chiaramente fatti male farlocchi faziosi
e da quelli che rimangono tra i delle
conclusioni l'evidence based medi sam
che l'attuale paradigma in ambito medico
sa in un periodo di forte crisi per
questo motivo perché si è sempre basata
sull'idea di noi abbiamo delle
pubblicazioni ipse dixit funziona fallo
questo modo di ragionare e decaduto in
questo momento perché il mare
televisione il mare di meta analisi e
magari di scrittura in cui viene a
trovarsi adesso in ambito scientifico
qualcuno è scoraggiante disorientante e
questo è pericoloso fece abbiamo di
fronte a delle persone
ora
prospettive per il futuro della nostra
generazione
roba che non s'era mai pensato prima
basta un padre di io ne parlo con un po
un po d'orgoglio perché questo arrivarci
è un futuro molto desiderabile veramente
tanto perché adesso le protesi sono
qualcosa di estremamente limitato
solamente per a ginosa e non riescono ad
essere abbastanza soggettive specifiche
per il soggetto né immaginiamo un futuro
dove tu se succede qualcosa hai la
possibilità di progettare una parte del
tuo corpo che si è fatto apposta le
spese proprio fatta su misura e quindi
tu non abbia il problema di doversi
adattare a questa se succede qualcosa ma
il problema è uno ed è grande l'uomo si
rapporta al corpo umano come un cane si
rapporta un radiatore di una macchina il
proprio mano è bellissimo e un orologio
senza loro già io non abbiamo idea di
preciso di come funziona ci siamo fatti
un'idea che stiamo facendo stupire
abbiamo fatti saranno fatti però è
un'idea non è la realtà è un modello e
quando qualcuno un problema noi
cerchiamo di riportarlo al modello che
abbiamo le cure cambiano tantissimo un
infartuato 50 anni fa ma per un
trattamento totalmente diverso da quello
che aura e questo ha una motivazione
perché la scienza deve essere
l'evoluzione la variazione di pensiero
falange lizzazione l'altra deve essere
costante altrimenti è immobilismo però
cosa possiamo fare per migliorare la
conoscenza che ne abbiamo bene questa
immagine è bellissima ha preso dal
necton project che cosa è un progetto
che dice va bene allora noi abbiamo il
cervello umano bello è che abbiamo
capito dopo tanto bene come funziona
immaginiamo di vederlo come un
supercomputer con una serie di fili che
collegano le varie parti bene come si
può schematizzare questo piccoletto un
progetto si occupa di questo immaginare
tutta la sostanza grigia che si trova
all'interno del sistema nervoso
collegata dei fasci sostanza bianca come
se fossero dei figli
che collegano computer quello che vedete
qua e le connessioni dell'encefalo
in rosso e verde le connessioni fra i
due emisferi e in blu vi faccio che la
vitali che si occupano della motilità
questa è una prospettiva futura perché
riuscire a capire di più su come
funziona il corpo umano è fondamentale
per riuscire a migliorare quella cura e
questa è roba che la generazione
precedente alla mia non vedeva neanche
lontanamente possibile visto che tutti
gli studi di neurologia urologia
funzionale cioè su come funzionano le
cose ma non ha strade non c'è più che
altro anatomici quindi su cosa si
riusciva a vedere dalle direzioni e ci
ha portato a fare una serie di errori
clamorosi negli anni passati questa è
una cosa che la generazione non deve
fare ora un attimo di prevenzione sulle
vaccinazioni le vaccinazioni sono
fondamentali le vaccinazioni sono
obbligatorie e più uno stato e civile
più dovrebbe aumentare il numero di
vaccinazioni obbligatorie
io vi dico questa cosa perché trovo
vergognoso che in uno stato come il
nostro sia permesso un così drastico
calo di vaccinazione perché questo
drastico calo di vaccinazioni può
portare a casi come è successo l'anno
scorso di bambine morte di percosse che
in questo paese non si vedeva da almeno
30 anni
e tutto questo perchè perchè delle
persone erano conte di saperne molto di
più di gente che su queste cose ci ha
studiato e a cosa è dovuto questo è
venuta a mancare la mediazione la
mediazione culturale sta decadendo non
ci si fida più di nessuno
piuttosto che affidarsi del medico o
dell'avvocato e del commercialista ci si
fida in continuazione di internet come
se internet per il solo fatto di essere
questo gigantesco conglomerato di idee
più persone abbia la conoscenza struga è
fondamentale riportare al centro della
discussione l'uomo e l'uomo da
intendersi proprio come le persone che
partecipano
bisogna ritornare affidarsi a fidarsi
delle persone che è fondamentale perché
altrimenti pasi che posso che possono
succedere questo
e non c'è la percezione fondamentale per
un altro motivo se chiuderlo 80 90 per
cento della popolazione vaccinata verso
una malattia
succede un fenomeno bellissimo che si
chiama in merito di greggio per cui se
una persona dall'esterno arriva con una
malattia non trovando nessuno sensibile
a questa malattia perché sono tutti
vaccinati non riesce a trasmetterla e
quindi non era una persona che non può
essere vaccinata e protetta una persona
che immunodepressa e non può essere
vaccinata bambino che è troppo piccolo e
non ha ancora fatto le vaccinazioni può
essere protette deve essere protetta la
vaccinazione deve essere un obbligo
sociale e non medico verso le altre
persone verso le fasce più deboli della
società e questo l'impegno che noi
dobbiamo avere forte perché e dove
l'attuale establishment sta fallendo
allora
ora parliamo di associazione e cosa
dell'associazione non riesci per fare a
meno di una droga ne abusi in maniera
compulsiva fino a quando voli giusto
questo è quello che chiunque pensi di
associazione e quello su quella attuale
teoria medica si basa per la cura
dell'associazione e da cosa derivano
questi esperimenti e di un topolino lo
metti una gabbia di tedio dispenser 1
con l'acqua con l'acqua di una tromba
prendiamo per esempio l'eroina questa
prima si attacca a quello con l'acqua è
l'eroina fino a quando la muore di
overdose semplice e logico ovvio
naturale fantastico non è vero perché
l'uomo non vive in una gabbia l'uomo era
di male sociale
l'uomo viveva un'altra persona come
possiamo riprodurre l'uomo non possiamo
iniziare a mente le persone all'interno
della gabbia gigantesca bene
l'esperimento dirà clarke che è stato
fatto e stata una cosa fondamentale
sotto questo punto di vista cosa si è
fatta si è messo tanti topolini anche di
sesso diverso hanno bisogno di sparare
anche loro tanti giochi qualcosa che si
produca al meglio l'ambiente di vita in
cui normalmente vivono le persone
perfetto cosa succede che nessuno dei
topi utilizzo a compulsivamente il
dispenser con la droga
nessuno di loro ne fa abuso nessuno di
loro ha smette di vivere in società per
utilizzarlo questo deve cambiare
parliamo delle grotte un problema
sociale non un problema medico
immaginate un materiale o dei piccoli
robot perché no che non inseriamo nel
corpo di un paziente
magari un paziente che soffre di tumore
e questi si localizzano vicino al comune
perché sono stati educati a riconoscere
e questo ci permette di vederle molto
meglio le tecniche di imaging perché
magari questi piccoli robot invece di
essere visibili sono pochi ci permette
di migliorare la terapia perché
concentra nel tempio terapico in un
luogo oppure non azione elite a loro
stessi e questo può portarci in futuro a
guarigione in situazioni dove adesso un
tumore metastatico che una condanna di
morte questo potrebbe non esserlo tra
vent'anni
però per fare tutto questo bisogna
crederci questa è la cosa fondamentale
in tutto questo crederci contro tutto
perché il sistema come abbiamo visto
tende a inglobati tende a preferire un
immobilismo che continui con te dentro
piuttosto che cambiare lei perché vuoi
cambiare tu contro tutti perché tutto
rema contro di te tutto tutte le persone
di cui ti circondi mano a mano che salì
vicino all establishment cercano di
avvicinarsi e soprattutto vederci atto e
lottare lottare perché chi lotta può
perdere chi non lotta ha già perso
buonasera